oh there's some like meat here we are
outside Trader Joe's or would the Wall
Street Journal looking through the
dumpster to see whether we can find
items that we can sell on Amazon Amazon
CEO Jeff Bezos has said there's a facet
of Amazon that goes largely unnoticed
there's a piece of our business which is
probably not fully appreciated which is
the third party seller part of our
business these are the sellers other
than Amazon selling on the Company's
sprawling online marketplace the
e-commerce giant has welcomed millions
of them in a quest to deliver on its
mission of vast product selection and
customer obsession third-party sellers
have also become a key part of the
company's growth strategy now as a
marketplace is many times more
profitable than Amazon a retail business
and thus it makes so much more sense for
Amazon to grow it as opposed to its own
retail operations an Amazon creates such
a uniform experience for the customer it
can be difficult to tell who's actually
doing the selling with the explosive
growth of third-party sellers on the
platform there's a continuous race to
the bottom it's become a race among
sellers to offer competitive low pricing
and win sales over others listing the
same products
so the job of a seller is trying to find
some way to source it cheaper than
everyone else all of this means your
product can come from just about
anywhere even a garbage dumpster The
Wall Street Journal identified a number
of sellers who claim they sell garbage
and secondhand products on Amazon some
even claim they sell these products as
new we're finding all of this crazy
stuff same answer
thrift stores we couldn't independently
verify sale of all these goods on the
site Amazon couldn't confirm the
storefronts of some of the dumpster
diving sellers The Wall Street Journal
identified most dumpsters sourcing
sellers refused to go on camera and
declined to give details about their
Amazon storefronts some citing fear of
getting kicked off the platform so we
put garbage up for sale on Amazon though
quickly bought the items ourselves so no
one else could we dug through garbage
dumpsters gathered various items
polished them up and listed them as new
on Amazon but first we got a glimpse
into one way sellers are able to take
they're on the cheap products whether
from thrift stores liquidation companies
or even garbage dumpsters and sell them
alongside the rest of Amazon's inventory
the key is the fulfilled by Amazon
service or FBA here's how FBA works
third-party sellers sign up and pay for
FPA then they send their products to
amazon fulfillment centers warehouses
that are located all over the US
[Music]
the products are then marked is eligible
for prime shipping Amazon's quick
delivery option when shopper buys an
item Amazon takes care of sending the
shipment to the customer so the purchase
arrives in an Amazon branded package or
with an Amazon label just like the goods
Amazon itself sells
rachel johnson greer previously managed
safety systems for amazon says the
branding FBA product received can
confuse customers anything that was
inside the fulfillment centers would get
the Prime badge because it could be
delivered at that speed so people
started ik waiting the prime batch with
amazon and i think at that point it
became obscured to customers that they
were buying from third-party sellers FBA
has been so successful for third-party
sellers that now an estimated 54% of
sellers on amazon send their inventory
to FBA warehouses and let amazon take
care of the rest
[Music]
Heather cooks has been an Amazon third
party seller since 2009 she is not a
dumpster diver but she does source
product on the cheap we have better
wheels on your pallet jack than I do
together with her husband she's built a
business through FBA over the past four
or five years here's a wet hair brush
that will probably go Amazon FBA or be
sold Amazon Prime these are a peel-off
mask I've sold these on Amazon as well
before and then you get some stuff that
looks like this the last time I open one
of these pallets I ended up with a used
dental guard which was gross that's
disgusting
I find that I sell my items much faster
because they're sitting at the Amazon
Fulfillment Center and more people want
to buy because they're paying for that
Prime membership they want that free
shipping and they want the to get it in
two days I see a clearance aisle down
this way we would do what's called
retail arbitrage where you just go out
and go hunting at a lot of big-box
stores
ooh this is a good one 50% off believe
it or not you can shop the clearance
aisle buy a toy after Christmas for five
dollars and flip it online for 20 and
then we kind of shifted to liquidation I
started buying big pallet now you're
going from spending two or three dollars
in items down to like 50 cents or $1 in
item what happens is all of those
big-box stores they end up with excess
inventory it goes into a pallet to a
liquidator and then they in turn either
sell it by the pallet or even back by
the truckload
when unboxing a pallet or a liquidation
case I go through and I find what's
gonna go to Amazon first because that's
the big monster of customer acquisition
something like this would probably go on
Amazon because it's in a good condition
and the package has not been opened I'm
gonna make sure the seals not broken of
the bottle on the inside and you can
clearly see everything is still totally
sealed and packaged fulfillment by
Amazon has helped me scale the business
I list under the already created listing
and then I put a label on it that says
it's mine it goes to my store and then I
ship it into the Amazon warehouse they
handle all the shipping they handle all
the customer returns and so the back end
of selling any item I have is just
completely taken away sealed video games
are great even if it's something you
don't think is worth anything just scan
it if it's sealed many sellers agree the
FBA designation gives their listings
more legitimacy and leads to greater
profits so as you can see there is
definitely money within dumpster diving
to test dumpster divers claims that
almost anything can be retrieved from
the garbage and sold on Amazon via FBA
this is the newest haul The Wall Street
Journal went on a few dumpster dives
collected dozens of products from a
variety of retail store dumpsters
including Trader Joe's
[Music]
after a little sprucing up three were
put up for sale on an FBA storefront
created by the journal we listed our
items as new and intentionally priced
them higher than other sellers to
discourage customers from buying them a
reporter from The Journal successfully
purchased the goods as soon as they were
listed to insure a customer didn't end
up with items from the garbage
both the stencil set and the paper
shipped in Amazon packaging not the
packaging in which the journal sent them
the lemon-curd however came back in the
same box the journal packaged again
still in the same bubble wrap and tape
but the only thing Amazon appeared to
have done was to put its own shipping
label on top of the journals a Trader
Joe's spokeswoman said the grocer
doesn't approve of the sale of any of
its products on Amazon Trader Joe's says
it's store policy to discard a product
only if it is unfit for sale following
the Wall Street Journal's reporting
amazon updated its policies and now
prohibits selling items from the trash
an amazon spokeswoman said the company
requires all products offered on the
site to comply with applicable laws and
regulations in Amazon's own policies
adding that the company expects sellers
to act honestly and fairly in accordance
with their seller code of conduct
she said that workers at Amazon's
fulfillment centers have the authority
to flag unacceptable products being
broken and expired items and prevent
them from being sent to customers
[Music]
since leaving Amazon Rachel Grier began
advising third-party sellers on the site
she says some sellers don't understand
the precautions and safety concerns
associated with sourcing inventory one
of the things that has been a challenge
is convincing a small business owner
that safety and compliance is important
if Amazon's not looking there is
absolutely nothing stopping you from
dumpster diving for food there's nothing
stopping you from doing the same thing
with toys that get tossed out nothing at
all I have heard and watched some people
do some dumpster diving that's not my
scene um but I don't know some people
think liquidation is a little bit like
that as well anything you send in Amazon
is super-important that it's going to be
pristine I love to have my hands
directly on each item because then I
know for sure it's in the quality and
it's in the condition that I really
really love Jeff Bezos credits Amazon
success as a company to its philosophy
of customer obsession if there's one
thing amazon.com is about its obsessive
attention to the customer experience
obsessive focus on the customer at the
very top of the list is customer
obsession the number one thing that has
made us successful by far is
obsessive-compulsive focus on the
customer
I do the third-party sellers that now
make up more than half of its sales
share in this commitment most sellers
are trying to benefit from Amazon sighs
Amazon is known to be consumer obsessed
sellers don't have to be due South Beach
live in Dubai and food on Amazon that is
a Amazon shipment getting ready to go I
mean that looks good enough to sell on
Amazon mints I think it's sellable
before publishing this video
Amazon removed The Wall Street Journal's
storefront Amazon said the storefront
offered products that were sourced in a
manner that violated Amazon's high bar
for customer trust and safety
[Music]
you